what's going on guys today I'm going to
explain every abnormal Tyson that's made
in appearance in the attack on Titan
anime over the years we've seen how
tones come in many different shapes and
sizes and while it would be easy to
assume that all the freaky looking ones
must be abnormal that's definitely not
always the case whereas normal pure
Titans can be expected to walk a certain
way and eat whoever's in front of them
abnormals will deviate from one or both
of those characteristics for example
they might purposefully walk past one
person so they can eat someone else
instead or they might do crazy stuff
like climbing up trees jumping like a
madman or hyping themselves up as they
go into battle as we'll see in the video
there are other things that make them
different but the point is that a Titan
doesn't need to have a weird face or
look like a character from Breaking Bad
to be abnormal but rather their behavior
and the way they move with the main
factors from this point on I'll be
explaining the different abnormals that
have made their marks on Attack on Titan
but before we get into it don't forget
to sub if you haven't already as I plan
to gradually explain everything worth
knowing about this series also I want to
thank surfshark for sponsoring this
video which should be the go-to VPN for
any of you looking to protect your
online privacy whether it be hackers
advertisers or even the government
there's always someone these days who
want to track our online movements but
surfshark secures your data by
encrypting all information sent between
your devices in the internet they do
such a good job the search art was
recently rated as the best VPN for
security by PC mag and what makes this
even better is that it's the only major
VPN that you can install on unlimited
devices for just one subscription I've
personally been using the app on both my
phone and laptop for over four months
now and besides protecting my data
wherever I am the interface in general
is just really smooth and easy to
understand for a limited time by going
to searchlight.deals Turtle work you can
get a mind-blowing 83 off a two-year
plan plus three months extra for free
which in simple terms means a
subscription will work out to just 2.21
cents a month understandably this deal
is only available for a very limited
time so click the link in the
description and use code Turlock work if
you want a cheap way to protect your
online privacy today
okay so in no particular order the first
abnormal in this video is often referred
to as the talking Titan but its weird
Behavior goes Way Beyond the fact that
it can speak to this day there are
certain things that only this pure Titan
has been shown to do including mourning
the death of someone it killed running
away from people instead of running
towards them and trying its hardest to
fight against his Titan instincts
initially this abnormal was introduced
in a special one-off chapter written by
isayama himself which was then later
adapted and expanded upon during an OVA
however in order to fully explain this
Titan we need to flash back even further
than this around 60 years before the
start of the series yamir was a false
prophet living in Mali who was worshiped
by a group of loyal followers those
followers believe she was a descendant
of Royal Blood and among them was this
woman who would one day become the
talking Titan once the group was
discovered by the Marlin authorities
everyone involved was sent to parodies
Island and this lady was seen directly
next to Emir before they returned into
pure Titans in the manga we saw the
result of their Transformations with the
talking Titan calling besides the Emir
Titan and following this moment they
presumably went their separate way
Flash Forward decades later and this
abnormal was just chilling in the woods
when it encountered a member of the
survey corps who was stranded in Titan
territory without a horse by pure
coincidence this particular Scout had a
strong physical resemblance to yamir
even down to their freckles and because
of this the talking Titan mistakenly
believed it was yamir herself that's why
rather than immediately trying to eat
her like a normal time would the
abnormal spent time heavily breathing
collecting his thoughts and eventually
speaking the first words to come out its
mouth were subject of yamir which in
hindsight was a massive hint as to the
nature of all aldians but at the time
this chapter came out there wasn't
enough information to make it make sense
after that it referred to the Scout as
lady Emir and bowed down as a sign of
respect something the members of The
Cult all used to do when they were human
anyway the abnormal went through a range
of emotions during this interaction as
it tried to fight against the natural
urge to eat the Scout literally tearing
away his own skin to suppress the
Instinct sadly though in the end it
couldn't resist and ate the girl's head
as she documented the details of what
happened in her notebook this same
notebook was discovered by Captain Levi
year later but before we get into that
it's worth noting that instead of eating
the rest of the body the abnormal buried
it inside a tree as another sign of
respect the area around this tree then
essentially became the Titan's home as
the OVA showed that it didn't like to
venture too far away from it and if it
did then it would try to run back there
as soon as possible hanji and a few
other Scouts were able to follow this
abnormal all the way to the burial site
and in the process they also found the
notebook which documented everything the
Titan had said after reading the journal
hanji became aware that the name yamir
had some sort of relevance to the Titans
hence why in season 2 she was incredibly
shocked to learn that one of the new
Scouts had that same name last thing to
mention on the talking Titan is that
although its fate was unknown in the
original chapter written by a sayama the
OVA added this extra scene in which Levi
cuts his name next up in season 4 the
one that contains the expinal fluid had
been drunk by a lot of people including
the 30 soldiers who were meant to be
making sure he didn't Escape as I
explained earlier abnormals behave or
move in unique ways and through the
power of pars the Beast item was able to
make abnormals specifically for the
forest environment whereas regular pure
Titans either struggle to climb trees or
just straight up can't do it Zeke
created ones that could easily climb and
swing between them at ridiculous speeds
when making Titan Zeke clearly has some
kind of ability to choose whether or not
to give them abnormal characteristics
because we all know that if those
soldiers have been turned into Titans
the normal way you'd be lucky if even
one of them could climb trees following
this we have what is Comfortably the
largest pure Titan to ever exist and
that is of course the rod rise Titan
according to Armin it was double the
size of the Colossal which makes it
around 120 meters tall and like certain
other abnormals its body proportions
just didn't make any sense if we zoom in
on this image here you can see that its
skinny chicken legs are not built to
support this super long torso and as a
result the Titan couldn't actually stand
without holding onto the walls is why I
literally crawled along the ground
instead of walking normally resulting in
its face being ripped off because of the
friction and its gross time organs
obviously fell all over the place
forgetting its massive size for a second
there are a few other things that also
make this Titan super weird with the
first being the fact that it chose to
ignore nearby humans once the Rampage
began Rod never even attempted to eat
any of the people who were closest to
him but rather he preferred to crawl for
hours until he reached the highly
populated Orville District that was
Miles Away on top of that the rice
Titan's body emitted a super hot steam
similar to what the Colossal can do
hence why the trees began to catch fire
whenever he approached and while the
scouts had to doubt themselves in cold
water
anyway it was implied by Kenny Ackerman
that the reason Roy became so large was
due to him licking the time
transformation serum off the floor
instead of injecting it properly because
if you don't do it right then stuff like
this is a possibility one other
interesting thing about this abnormal is
that when a story adopt the finishing
bow to its name she was able to see
certain memories from his life ranging
from his childhood all the way till
nearly the present day this is a
phenomenon that has never occurred when
other pure Titans have been killed but
given that they're both of Royal Blood
we have to assume that that is somehow
the reason moving over to the jumping
Titan now I actually love this abnormal
because the way it changed the whole
vibe of the episode it just perfectly
encapsulates what made early Attack on
Titan so amazing before the jumping
Titan appeared the mood was generally
hopeful with Aaron talking about how
quickly they could rise to the ranks and
Thomas suggesting they should do a
challenge to see who could kill the most
titans the heroic background music
played as the sunshine down on these
guys but a second later the abnormal
Titan appears the Music Stops and Thomas
is eaten alive while his friends can
only stand there and watch in less than
a few minutes we went from nervous
excitement to completely charm
traumatized while the abnormal then just
got to walk away like nothing happened
much later on the jumping Titan was
killed by Aaron's Revenge with the
attack Titan biting into its nape with
full force and then just throwing the
body away in season 3 there was a
different abnormal created by the
Marlins and much like what writes its
movement was severely impaired by having
legs that couldn't support its weight
the sad thing about this particular
Titan is that it was crawling for an
unknown number of years trying to reach
the wall and at some point it just gave
up and gradually went dead behind the
eyes when approached by the scouts it
never once diverted its eyes away from
the ground showing that even the
presence of people was no longer
something that could awaken its Titan
instincts or even its human instincts it
was just an empty shell while the fate
of this title was never revealed in my
head there are two realistic options
either they put it out of its misery on
their return to the walls or they left
it there for years in the hope that one
day something would turn it back into a
human judging by how Aaron acted towards
it in the anime and considering that
another Titan was also given the same
treatment I'd say the second option is a
strong possibility but let me know what
you think in comments down below the
next abnormals appeared during the
attack on Earth guard Castle in season 2
and even for abnormals their behavior is
virtually unexplainable although both
abnormals were created by Zeke that in
itself doesn't explain why they would
attack each other as you know he gains
Nothing by making two of his Creations
fight between themselves my purely
speculative guess is that these two
might have actually been young siblings
back in ragako Village as the way they
were interacting kind of reminded me of
kids play fighting just on a larger and
more violent scale from what I remember
this was the first and only time that
two pure Titans just randomly started
fighting without being given
instructions and you know them being
siblings it would make this make some
sort of sense but ultimately that is
just a theory
anyhow one thing I forgot to mention is
that technically speaking every single
Titan Zeke makes is an abnormal even the
ones that seem normal since all of them
are able to function at night when the
moon is out this is something regular
pure Titans can't do as they need
sunlight to operate whereas Titans made
by the Beast can move in both sunlight
and Moonlight making all of them
abnormals by definition that being said
though some of them are clearly more
unpredictable than others with a notable
example being Connie's mother who was
the second talking pure Titan in the
series on Connie's return to ragako this
Titan famously said welcome home to her
son proving that she retains some
connection to her human consciousness
what was funny about this whole thing
was the way Rhino definitely also heard
the Titan speak but had to Gaslight Cody
and make him seem like he was crazy for
hearing something that they both 100
heard the design of Connie's mother's
Titan was unique due to the exposed rib
cage and skinny limbs meaning it was
unable to move and was therefore Left
Alive in the village as it didn't really
present a threat to anyone other
especially weird abnormals made by Zeke
include the posing Titan the gymnast
Titan and the button ugly Titan that had
his head partially exploded by the man
himself during the 57th Expedition
beyond the walls we saw a couple more
abnormals not made by the Beast Titan
the first of which was this freak who
was resting inside a derelict house it's
no exaggeration to say that this Titan
was inches away from killing Sasha and
what made it abnormal was the unique way
its legs allowed it to maneuver on all
fours this Titan was eventually knocked
out by being led into a tree however
because the nape was never destroyed we
can assume it survived until presumably
being killed by the execution from hell
at some point a different Titan then
appeared immediately afterwards and
besides walking like it has severe
constipation this abnormal ignored the
people around it in favor of heading
towards the center of the formation
while it was quickly dealt with by
experienced Soldiers the celebrations
didn't last long because Annie appeared
like a minute later and uh yeah we all
know what happens after that
flashing back to early that same season
Mikasa killed an abnormal entrust that
was wildly sprinting towards the
innocent civilians and this was the
moment that inspired Louise to become a
scout as well as being mikas's very
first on-screen Titan kill
in The Clash of the Titans Emir pointed
out this abnormal here who was patiently
observing the four Titan shifts in the
trees above it and I guess the thing
that makes my abnormal is his
intelligence unlike the other pure
Titans around it it knew that it
couldn't climb the tree so instead it
casually laid down and focused his eyes
on them waiting for them to hopefully
make a mistake by that same standard I
guess this time here is abnormal too as
it was taking time to just stand still
and observe its targets instead of
immediately trying to eat them
technically speaking the dynafrix Titan
is also abnormal if we consider that she
walked past battle without trying to
kill him although considering the full
context of the manga I think it's fair
to say that her usual behavior is that
of a regular Titan lastly as of
recording this video the final abnormal
to appear in the attack on Titan anime
is the war Titan that was discovered
following the fight between Annie and
Aaron I plan to do a video dedicated to
the wall Titans in the not too distant
future so for this video all I'll say is
that if a pure Titan is the size of a
freaking colossal then that is enough to
meet the abnormal criteria for me anyhow
there were one or two random Titans in
trolls that I wasn't sure about that
might have been abnormals too but for
the most part I think we mentioned
everyone that's appeared in the series
if you enjoyed this video then be sure
to drop a like and hit that sub button
so you don't miss future content like
this and until the next one peace out